- How many questions,
the same thing?
Put out content.
Put out a great product.
Test things. Try it all.
Use data.
Use your intuition.
Test and learn,
test and learn, test and learn.
And this just insane lack
of patience and lack of
understanding that takes
actual skills to actually
win is frustrating at times.
What does a local business
need to do to get customers?
You need to have a great product,
you need to make people
that could potentially buy
your product know about it.
You can do that
through content,
you can do that
through advertising,
you can do that by going to the
Chamber of Commerce,
you can do that by
fucking cold calling every
single business in town.
Fuck, man.
There's just so
many ways to do it.
But one way not to do it
is to watch my videos and
read Seth Godin's books and
ponder and strategize and
white board all day and
debate with your brother
and wonder why.
Lack of action is
one way not to do it.
One thing that I'm doing is
I'm constantly in motion.
I'm changing my products,
I'm changing my game.
I'm changing.
All the time, I'm redoing my
pitch deck for VaynerMedia.
I've got different
ideas of how to sell it.
Fucking, learn how
to love losing.
Learn how to love
losing like I do.
You know why I'm not
scared of testing 'cause
I don't fear the loss.
I don't fear
people laughing at me.
Fucking laugh at me.
Go ahead, laugh at me.
I don't give a fuck.
Try to laugh at me.
Laugh at me with your opinions.
Let's talk results.
You know who can laugh at me?
People that are beating me.
Zucks, you're allowed to laugh.
Elon, you're allowed to laugh.
Sacca, laugh at me.
You're allowed.
If you're not beating me,
don't fucking laugh.
People are scared.
People are scared of
trying new things.
People are students.
You're students.
You're not
a fucking entrepreneur.
You're a student.
You're a student, all you want
to do is read and consume and
ponder and make pretend and
talk about how you're gonna.
Fuck your "gonna."
Go do it.
You can only read so much.
You have to do.
I'm an extreme
maybe I'm different.
I don't learn that way.
I don't read anything
and that's not right.
But is it right to
read all of them?
Shit.
How many fucking books from
these experts do you need?
Do shit.
Learn.
Put in the work.
Don't fucking have dinner at
7 o'clock and drink two beers and
have the fucking Spurs-Golden
State game in the background
with your two buddies
and tell each other
how you're gonna do it.
While you're fucking sitting there
how you're gonna do it
and dap, I haven't seen fucking
Steph Curry hit a
basket this year.
(triumphant music)
Just go do.
My biggest goal is
that I have no fans.
That my fans learn from me
and get inspired from me
and then don't consume me.
I don't care how big my
subscription numbers are or
how many people follow me.
I don't want you here.
I never want to hit a million
subscribers on YouTube.
I don't want you here.
I don't need it.
I don't need that.
I need to make an impact.
I want the legacy of
you coming up to me.
Last night, at my meet-up
the 400 people,
300 people showed up,
40 of them
whispered in my ear
"You changed my life."
That's what I get off on.
Not them still buying my books
or buying my courses or
being a VaynerMedia
client, I want legacy.
I've made enough money.
I'm good.
I'm great.
If I don't make a
single dollar again, great.
I don't need to buy the Jets,
I need to try to buy the Jets.
That a distinction.
I want legacy.
I want you to show that my
funeral because you watched a
Facebook live stream when I was
in San Diego and I ranted and
I finally kicked your ass into
gear and you realized
no more reading.
No more consuming.
Time to do.
Try to put your fears in action.
Great you go 0-for-70?
I love when people
don't hire us.
I love you're moving,
you're constantly moving.
That's how you have to do it.
You can't just think and ponder
and read Medium and wonder and
watch one more book and order 10
more you udemy courses and
go to four more
fucking conferences.
Enough listening.
Start doing shit.
Don't be scared.
It's action,
it's going, it's doing.
(light music)